As you might know, Shanghai is a very developed city.
Its buildings and clean city views will amaze you,...
...but here is one thing you should not miss especially if you have kids.
Take Shanghai Metro Line 1 and get off at the Circus World station.
Here at Gonghe Xin Lu Road, you will find China's number one circus attraction.
This is a great place for your kids to appreciate the creatively designed performances.
This 22,500 square meter complex has a 1,638-seat circus theater...
...with a revolving, lifting and picture frame stage,...
...high-tech acoustics and computer-guided lighting.
There is an enormous animal house, which holds rooms for elephants, lions, tigers,...
...horses, chimps and pandas, with state-of-the-art facilities.
The famous Shanghai Acrobatic Troupe often performs here.
In November each year, you can visit the Shanghai International Magic Festival.
Don't worry if the more expensive tickets are sold out because all the seats have great views.